- Alexandre Poussart: Bonjour à
tous.
Ravi de vous retrouver pour un
nouveau numéro de "Parlement
hebdo".
On va revenir sur l'actualité de
la semaine parlementaire.
- Kathia Gilder: Nous accueillons
Benjamin Saint-Huile, député du
Nord et porte-parole de Libertés,
indépendants, outre-mer et
territoires.
- Alexandre Poussart: On va parler
de la proposition de loi de votre
groupe pour abroger le recul de
l'âge de départ à la retraite à 64
ans.
Le débat est prévu dans
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée le 8
juin.
La majorité présidentielle et le
gouvernement estiment que le texte
n'est pas recevable financièrement
et que le débat ne doit pas avoir
lieu.
On va parler d'immigration.
Le gouvernement tente de trouver
une majorité sur son projet de
loi.
Les Républicains ont dévoilé deux
propositions de loi sur ce sujet,
notamment un texte qui prévoit de
modifier la Constitution pour
durcir la politique migratoire de
notre pays.
Les députés sont sur le projet de
loi de programmation militaire, un
budget de 413 milliards d'euros
pour les armées pour permettre à
la France de faire face aux
nouvelles menaces.
- Kathia Gilder: On parle d'abord
des retraites.
Votre groupe présente ce texte
pour abroger la mesure phare de la
réforme, le recul à 64 ans de
l'âge de départ à la retraite.
La présidente de la commission des
Affaires sociales a saisi Eric
Coquerel, président de la
commission des Finances, sur la
recevabilité du texte.
- Je l'ai saisi, ayant moi-même
été interpellée par de nombreux
députés de la majorité
présidentielle qui, effectivement,
se posaient la question de la
recevabilité.
Je comprends qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'une paille.
Il s'agit de 20 milliards.
Le débat, on l'a déjà eu.
Il y a eu des heures de débats en
séance, en commission.
On remet une pièce dans le
juke-box inutilement.
- Je vais chercher les arguments
juridiques en lien avec la
jurisprudence, par rapport à des
propositions de loi, en lien aussi
avec les compensations, voir si je
peux la déclarer recevable.
Je vais chercher.
Je peux pas donner la réponse
aujourd'hui, mais je vais essayer
d'aller dans ce sens-là, comme je
le fais sur toutes les
propositions de loi.
Il faut laisser l'initiative
parlementaire prendre le pas.
- Kathia Gilder: Est-ce que vous
craignez que votre proposition de
loi, qui abroge le recul de l'âge
de départ à la retraite à 64 ans,
soit déclarée irrecevable
financièrement?
- Benjamin Saint-Huile: C'est la
panique, du côté du gouvernement
et de la majorité parlementaire.
"Cachez ce vote que je ne saurais
voir".
Depuis la Ve République, les
propositions de loi sont déposées.
Elles coûtent de l'argent, mais
par principe, pour permettre que
le travail parlementaire puisse se
faire dans un climat de sérénité,
c'est toujours accepté.
Cette proposition de loi a été
reçue par le bureau de l'Assemblée
nationale et validée en tant que
telle.
La seule personne qui puisse être
interpellée, c'est le président de
la commission des Finances, Eric
Coquerel.
Je suis inquiet quand j'entends la
Première ministre et les ministres
et secrétaires d'Etat se succéder
pour dire: "Mon Dieu, il y a un
caractère irrecevable, voire
irresponsable", alors que dans
leur majorité, nous étudiions des
textes qui devaient coûter
plusieurs milliards d'euros et que
ça ne posait de problème à
personne.
Il faut que les masques tombent.
On parle de 20 milliards.
Avant, c'était 15 milliards.
Les choses avancent vite.
Il y a deux articles.
Le premier, c'est l'abrogation du
recul de l'âge légal.
Le deuxième, c'est une conférence
sociale convoquée dans le deuxième
semestre 2023 pour trouver des
solutions et retrouver
l'équilibre.
Quand on vous dit "C'est
irresponsable", c'est un mensonge.
L'étude d'impact qui était fait
par le gouvernement...
Les mesures auront un impact de
270 à plus de 300 milliards.
Disons la vérité aux Français.
- Alexandre Poussart: Emmanuel
Macron a peur d'aller au vote sur
ce texte?
- Benjamin Saint-Huile: Oui.
Le président de la République, ou
plus exactement le gouvernement et
la majorité relative au Parlement,
ont peur du vote des députés.
Ils ont peur de perdre.
Ils savent le caractère
symbolique.
Ils savent qu'ils sont passés en
force.
La rue s'est mobilisée pendant des
mois jusqu'à se mettre en
difficulté financière à travers
des grèves pacifiques, que nous
avons travaillé dans l'Assemblée
nationale pour dire notre
désaccord...
Nous avons eu des gens qui nous
ont dit, la main sur le coeur:
"Rassurez-vous, sur ce texte
central, il y aura bien sûr un
vote".
Depuis, c'est la fracture dans le
pays.
Depuis, ce sont les casserolades.
Il y a une forme de blocage.
Il faut sortir de cette situation
dans laquelle le gouvernement nous
a plongés, sortir de cette
situation en accueillant la main
tendue du groupe LIOT.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous irez tout de
même jusqu'au bout, si votre
proposition est considérée comme
irrecevable?
Une motion de censure?
- Benjamin Saint-Huile: Nous avons
dit que nous voulions faire
confiance au vote, et que si vote
il y a, nous respecterions le
résultat.
Ou l'abrogation est prononcée par
un vote majoritaire, ce que nous
croyons, et nous en appelons à la
responsabilité du chef de l'Etat,
ou ce vote est rejeté, et
l'abrogation est rejetée, et nous
en prendrons acte.
Respecter la démocratie, c'est
accepter le fait majoritaire d'un
côté comme de l'autre.
Il y a une appréciation à
géométrie variable de la majorité
parlementaire.
- Alexandre Poussart: On va en
parler, mais juste, si ce texte
n'est pas examiné et déclaré
irrecevable, est-ce que LIOT va
déposer une motion de censure?
- Benjamin Saint-Huile: C'est trop
tôt pour le dire.
Tout est bloqué, aujourd'hui,
dehors, et il y a des urgences.
L'inflation continue à galoper.
Il y a des violences auxquelles
nous sommes confrontés, le service
public, l'hôpital...
Aujourd'hui, il y a une crispation
liée à la manière de faire du
gouvernement, à cette surdité
coupable du gouvernement.
Il faut en sortir.
Ils ne font aucune proposition
d'apaisement.
Nous voulons apaiser.
Je n'imagine pas qu'ils vont
choisir, une fois encore, d'éviter
le vote.
- Kathia Gilder: Et s'ils le
faisaient?
Ce serait mettre de l'huile sur le
feu?
- Benjamin Saint-Huile: Il y a une
forme d'irresponsabilité à
imaginer bloquer cette
proposition.
C'est une main tendue qui leur
permettrait d'apaiser le pays.
Depuis quand on a peur du vote à
l'Assemblée nationale?
- Alexandre Poussart: Vous pensez
avoir une majorité sur cette
proposition de loi?
Vous parlez avec Les Républicains?
- Benjamin Saint-Huile: Oui, avec
les groupes, mais nous pensons
aussi à la réaction du
gouvernement et à la minorité
présidentielle qui témoigne du
fait qu'il y a un vrai sujet sur
la capacité que nous pourrions
avoir à être majoritaires sur ce
texte.
C'est la panique.
Ca tremble, ça change d'avis.
Ils vont trouver toutes les
ficelles possibles et imaginables,
comme l'article 40, que nous
découvrons.
Ils vont peut-être utiliser
l'article 44.3.
Les gens ne comprennent pas cette
attitude.
Ils veulent savoir si à
l'Assemblée, il y a une majorité
pour abroger ce texte.
Nous savons que oui.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous pensez que
les Français s'intéressent à votre
initiative?
Ils ne sont pas passés à autre
chose?
- Benjamin Saint-Huile: Je pense
qu'ils sont très attentifs à ce
qu'il se passe.
Les dernières enquêtes d'opinion
témoignent qu'ils valident à plus
de deux tiers la proposition de
loi.
Il y a la volonté d'un vote.
Il y a peut-être une lassitude,
mais pourquoi?
Elle est liée au sentiment de ne
pas être entendus.
Les gens ont défilé pendant des
semaines pacifiquement et pris le
temps de faire grève, d'entamer
leur pouvoir d'achat.
Je croise des gens chaque jour qui
me disent: "Merci de continuer.
Nous, nous ne pouvons plus
descendre dans la rue parce que
financièrement, ce n'est plus
possible".
- Alexandre Poussart: Pour
conclure, si l'Assemblée adoptait
ce texte, il serait rejeté par le
Sénat, puisque la majorité de
droite du Sénat est pour la
réforme des retraites.
Ce texte n'ira jamais au bout?
- Benjamin Saint-Huile: Nous avons
considéré depuis le premier jour
qu'essayer de renvoyer ce texte au
Sénat, ce n'était pas un argument
sérieux.
Ce que veulent savoir les gens,
c'est ce que pensent les députés.
Ils veulent savoir si ceux qui les
représentent sont d'accord ou pas
avec cette réforme.
S'il y a un vote sur ce texte, il
y aura un vote majoritaire pour
l'abrogation.
C'est de la responsabilité du
président de la République d'en
prendre acte.
Il faut changer de gouvernement,
d'abord, et prendre acte que cette
réforme n'est pas acceptée, en
faisant en sorte qu'en quelques
mois, on réécrive une méthode
concertée, partagée.
- Alexandre Poussart: Pour faire
une autre réforme des retraites?
- Benjamin Saint-Huile:
Evidemment.
Ca peut se faire en quelques mois.
- Alexandre Poussart: On va parler
d'immigration, maintenant.
Le ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald
Darmanin consulte les
parlementaires sur son projet de
loi.
Les Républicains ont décidé de
dévoiler deux propositions de loi
sur ce thème, notamment une
proposition de loi
constitutionnelle pour durcir la
politique migratoire.
Ce sont des textes qui vont avoir
besoin des voix des centristes
pour être adoptés au Sénat.
Ce n'est pas gagné.
-
Les Républicains durcissent le
ton sur l'immigration.
L'exécutif a besoin de la droite
pour faire voter sa loi prévue à
l'automne.
- Une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle pour permettre
la convocation d'un référendum sur
l'immigration.
La loi actuelle ne le permet pas.
L'objectif est aussi de faire
valoir la primauté du droit
national sur le droit européen.
- Il n'y a pas un autre phénomène
qui ait autant bouleversé les
Français au cours du demi-siècle.
Je souhaite qu'un référendum
puisse avoir lieu sur le sujet de
l'immigration.
Il faut réviser la Constitution.
- Gérald Darmanin dénonce un
Frexit migratoire et rappelle les
lignes rouges du gouvernement.
- Vous proposez de sortir de la
Convention de Genève.
Si c'est vrai, c'est une question
importante.
Il faut que nous puissions
échanger sur la Constitution.
Je veux redire que j'ai entrepris
des négociations avec le groupe LR
du Sénat, avec les centristes et
les autres groupes qui le
souhaitent, pour discuter à
l'automne de ce texte.
- Le président du groupe centriste
au Sénat prend ses distances
vis-à-vis de son allié LR.
- Nous allons faire nos
propositions.
Elles seront différentes.
Nous sommes européens, à
l'évidence, et nous sommes
attentifs au cadre européen.
La Constitution est importante.
- La droite réclame la suppression
de l'aide médicale d'Etat pour les
sans-papiers.
- Alexandre Poussart: Est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec Les
Républicains?
Il faut déroger à certains traités
internationaux pour prendre le
contrôle de la politique
migratoire?
- Benjamin Saint-Huile: Je parle
aux Républicains ou à ceux qui
veulent copier les textes de
Marine Le Pen?
Il y a une volonté dans ce pays de
réguler, car c'est nécessaire, et
il y a une volonté d'encadrer les
choses différemment, mais faire
croire aux gens qu'on va réviser
la Constitution alors que cela
nécessite des procédures
complexes, et ne pas assumer que,
perdus dans leur idéologie, ils
hésitent entre une partie qui
regarde Emmanuel Macron en
cherchant les différences, et
l'autre qui regarde madame Le Pen
avec des yeux de Chimène, je suis
inquiet.
La droite républicaine que j'ai
connue, celle qui m'a fait grandir
autour de Jacques Chirac, elle me
semble un peu perdue dans cette
aventure.
Les Républicains cherchent
aujourd'hui à reprendre de la
lumière parce qu'ils sont dans une
situation de cul-de-sac, sans
issue.
Ceux qui choisissent de copier
madame Le Pen prennent un grand
risque.
Il faut d'abord réviser la
Constitution.
Ca dépend dans quel contexte on
pose le sujet.
Si on agite des peurs en
permanence en disant: "Regardez
tous ces gens, cette vague
submersible", pour reprendre les
expressions qu'ils utilisent à
tout rompre, vous agitez une
inquiétude dans la population qui
va amener à un vote de défense.
Sur ces sujets, il faut être
précis.
Nous avons besoin de
l'immigration.
Ca embête de dire ça, aujourd'hui,
mais dans nos hôpitaux, nous avons
besoin de main-d'oeuvre.
Dans beaucoup de secteurs tendus,
comme la restauration, nous sommes
heureux d'avoir de la
main-d'oeuvre étrangère.
Les propositions qui ont été
faites en ce sens elles doivent
être accompagnées.
Il faut arrêter de copier madame
Le Pen.
Il faut être sérieux.
Je considère que Les Républicains
choisissent la facilité.
- Alexandre Poussart: Gérald
Darmanin travaille sur son projet
d'immigration.
C'est un texte qui facilite les
expulsions tout en proposant de
régulariser les travailleurs
sans-papiers dans les secteurs
économiques en tension.
Est-ce que le groupe LIOT pourra
voter ce texte?
- Benjamin Saint-Huile: Nous
ferons ce que nous avons toujours
fait.
Nous allons proposer des
amendements, des améliorations.
Nous considérons que permettre à
ceux qui sont déjà ici et qui
travaillent de pouvoir être en
situation régulière, c'est
souhaitable.
Il faut mieux réguler.
Il y a quand même des choses sur
lesquelles il faut être plus
attentif, comme la question du
travailleur jetable, qu'on accepte
au moment de la tension et qu'on
remercierait une fois que la
tension serait derrière nous.
Il faut travailler à cela.
Il faut le faire avec modération.
- Kathia Gilder: Le gouvernement a
beaucoup tergiversé sur ce sujet.
Il y a eu un premier texte qui a
été retiré, finalement, puis le
revoici.
Est-ce que vous pensez que Gérald
Darmanin va trouver une majorité
sur l'immigration?
- Benjamin Saint-Huile: Je ne suis
pas sûr que ce gouvernement sera
en situation de continuer à
travailler comme il le fait.
Je ne vise pas Gérald Darmanin
spécifiquement.
Il est capable de construire des
passerelles.
Je trouve que, de manière
générale, la méthode choisie par
le gouvernement est une méthode
qui vise à considérer que les
oeillères d'hier doivent toujours
être conservées.
Ils ont vécu un mandat de cinq ans
dans une situation où ils
décidaient de tout seuls.
Ils n'ont pas intégré l'élection
présidentielle qui a fragilisé
notre institution à tous, avec une
extrême droite qui continue à
monter.
Ils n'ont pas intégré qu'ils
étaient en majorité relative.
Dans ce cas-là, on a une
responsabilité plus grande, celle
de créer les conditions du
compromis avec des gens qui ne
pensent pas comme nous.
Force est de constater que quand
il s'agit de textes plus
difficiles où le dialogue est
nécessaire, ils en ont été,
jusqu'à présent, incapables.
De manière générale, c'est la
méthode du gouvernement qui doit
être revue.
Je pense qu'on a affaire à des
gens qui, étant majoritaires, et
je le vois au gouvernement...
On a des gens qui travaillent,
mais qui ne comprennent pas de
quoi il s'agit.
Les gens du groupe LIOT viennent
du territoire, de droite comme de
gauche, et avec un fil conducteur,
celui d'avoir été en
responsabilité à l'échelle locale.
Il y a la responsabilité de faire
avancer les choses dans l'intérêt
général.
Aller chercher le voisin ou celui
d'en face, faire un pas vers lui,
c'est sortir des postures et ne
pas considérer qu'on a raison.
- Kathia Gilder: On va parler de
la LPM.
- 413 milliards d'euros de
dépenses entre 2024 et 2030, c'est
40% de plus que pour la précédente
loi de programmation militaire.
Objectif: transformer l'armée
française et faire face aux
nouvelles menaces.
- On vit dans un monde dangereux,
avec le retour de la guerre en
Europe.
On est aussi dans un monde avec
des mutations technologiques
importantes.
La France a besoin de rester au
meilleur niveau.
- Un quart du budget sera consacré
aux effectifs et à l'amélioration
des rémunérations.
Le gouvernement table sur 275
militaires et civils de plus à
l'horizon 2030.
Autre objectif: consolider le
stock de munitions et commander
130 blindés supplémentaires.
Les Républicains et le
Rassemblement National pointent du
doigt la répartition de l'effort
budgétaire.
- Il faut savoir comment.
Ce qui est inquiétant, c'est de
voir que les plus gros
investissements arrivent après
2027, comme si le gouvernement
avait voulu attirer la lumière sur
cette loi de programmation
militaire en laissant ses
successeurs la charge de trouver
les ressources.
- Parmi les priorités, l'entretien
et la modernisation de la
dissuasion nucléaire.
La France Insoumise questionne sa
pertinence.
- Rien ne garantit que cette
dissuasion sera efficace dans les
30 prochaines années.
Nous voulons réaffirmer
l'engagement de la France dans le
traité de non-prolifération
nucléaire, qui, dans l'article 6,
dit que l'objectif est la
dénucléarisation du monde.
- Le texte sera soumis au vote des
députés le 7 juin.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous êtes prêt à
voter cette loi?
- Benjamin Saint-Huile: Nous
considérons que le monde a changé,
que l'Europe qui se considérait en
paix vit malheureusement depuis
l'agression de Vladimir Poutine en
Ukraine une situation instable.
La France doit elle-même créer les
conditions pour être en situation
de faire face à cette nouvelle
situation.
Je veux dire que nous avons un
certain nombre d'amendements à
reporter.
Je pense à la question des
outre-mer, mais pas seulement.
Ce que nous disons, c'est que ce
gouvernement a pris une habitude:
celle de projeter à long terme les
politiques publiques.
Sans doute que cela peut avoir un
intérêt, mais cela peut aussi
différer une forme de
responsabilité publique.
Moi qui suis élu local, si vous
dites aux gens: "On met en place
une trajectoire jusque 2040 et on
commencera à voir les effets en
2030..."
Laurent Jacobelli reprend certains
propos qui ont déjà été dits chez
nous.
Je pense à la question des
énergies.
Est-ce que nous sommes d'accord
sur l'orientation politique?
Oui, moyennant un certain nombre
d'amendements.
Sur la méthode, je considère que
la visée de long terme doit
trouver des réponses concrètes
plus rapidement.
- Alexandre Poussart: Pour
augmenter notre base de
réservistes, le gouvernement
réfléchit à remettre en place le
service militaire, sur la base du
volontariat.
Ca durerait entre 3 et 6 mois.
C'est une bonne idée?
- Benjamin Saint-Huile: C'est de
la communication.
Tout le monde sait que ça coûte
beaucoup d'argent.
Si on doit faire de la politique,
on doit faire quelque chose de
simple.
Quand j'ai un billet de 100 euros
et que je fais de la politique, je
dois me demander où je mets mes
100 euros.
- Alexandre Poussart: On regarde
l'agenda de la semaine prochaine
au Parlement.
- Kathia Gilder: Mardi 30 mai, la
séance reprend avec cette loi de
programmation militaire qui est au
menu pour la deuxième semaine,
jusqu'au vote.
Le 31 mai, place à l'examen de
votre proposition de loi, celle du
groupe LIOT, pour abroger le recul
de l'âge de départ effectif à la
retraite.
- Alexandre Poussart: Mardi, la
commission d'enquête sur le fonds
Marianne poursuit ses auditions.
Bruno Le Maire va présenter le
projet de loi industrie verte.
Après la démission du maire de
Saint-Brevin, victime des
violences de l'extrême droite, les
sénateurs vont entendre le préfet
du Pays-de-la-Loire et le
sous-préfet de Saint-Nazaire.
Pour finir, on va parler des
violences.
Qu'est-ce que vous proposez pour
mieux protéger les agents publics?
- Benjamin Saint-Huile: Nous
sommes dans une société de plus en
plus violente, particulièrement là
où certains représentent
l'institution.
C'est vrai pour nos forces de
l'ordre, pour nos forces de
sécurité, pour nos fonctionnaires,
pour nos élus.
Nous devons nous interroger sur ce
que nous pouvons faire
collectivement pour les protéger
en termes de prévention, et pour
que les réponses apportées à ces
situations inacceptables soient
beaucoup plus importantes.
De manière générale, il faut aussi
être conscient que l'Assemblée est
une caisse de résonance et qu'il y
a un devoir d'exemplarité de
celles et de ceux qui prennent la
parole.
La violence, même si elle est
verbale, même si elle est
symbolique, elle peut être
répercutée dehors comme une forme
de légitimation, ce que nous
réfutons.
- Kathia Gilder: Qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de la "décivilisation"
de la société?
- Benjamin Saint-Huile: J'imagine
que des conseillers sérieux lui
ont proposé ce terme.
Je pense que, quoi qu'il en soit,
il faut investir sur l'éducation,
il faut choisir d'être au plus
près de notre jeunesse, et il faut
restaurer une forme de
responsabilité dans la parole
publique, de modération.
- Kathia Gilder: Ce sera le mot de
la fin.
- Alexandre Poussart: Merci
d'avoir suivi cette émission.